Yo this protein needs to fold faster.
Add some AI to it.
Hello world,
it's Saroj.
And last month an AI lab called deep mind entered their algorithm,
dubbed Alpha fold into a competition to predict the shapes of proteins and won.
This is a big deal,
unlike the rest of the teams.
Deepmind had zero experience in molecular biology,
yet they still beat top pharmaceutical companies with a hundred k plus employees
like Pfizer at this challenge.
And not only that,
they won by an unusually large margin over second place.
Deep mind demonstrated that an engineering solution,
not necessarily a breakthrough insights could accelerate scientific discovery.
Deep Mind,
we'll probably release the Alpha fold code and paper later this year,
but I just couldn't wait for that.
So I went ahead and recreate it.
It programmatically as best I could.
I'll explain the theory and code in this video.
Click subscribe if you haven't yet,
but before we do that,
we need to zoom out to see the bigger picture here.
Okay.
Not that far.
Almost everything new,
all knowledge and innovation in science and technology centers around one of
three ideas.
The atom,
the bite,
and the gene.
All three are building blocks,
basic organizational units of a larger whole,
the Adam for matter,
the bites for digitized information and the gene for biological information
matter.
Information in biology are all inherently hierarchically organized.
Understanding the smallest part is crucial to understanding the whole,
and while these three ideas have dominated science and technology in the 20th
century,
their convergence will dominate the 21st Alpha fold is the perfect example of a
convergence between two biology and information.
The gene and the bite.
A gene is a region of DNA that encodes some instructions.
DNA is the blueprint for all living things.
A copy of it is found in every cell of an organism from a strand of your hair to
your moneymaker.
Think of it like software and the cell with its molecular machinery is the
hardware running the software.
DNA needs a living cell to carry out its instructions in the proper setting.
These instructions are powerful,
producing a whole human being from just a single cell as it did with each of us
during our eight months of gestation in the womb.
DNAS.
Instructions are used to make proteins.
The complex molecules that do most of the work in our bodies.
The instructions of DNA are transcribed to an intermediary molecule called RNA.
The information contained in RNA molecules are translated into the language of
amino acids,
which are the building blocks of proteins.
This language tells the cells protein making machinery the precise order in
which to link the amino acids to produce a specific protein.
This is a big task because there are 20 types of amino acids which can be placed
in a whole lot of different orders to form a wide variety of proteins.
These proteins fight viruses,
transmit signals to coordinate biological processes,
provide structural support for cells,
transport molecules act.
As storage devices make you swole.
They have a huge range of functions in the body.
Proteins are complex molecules.
They aren't stable in their unfolded or fully extended shape.
They spontaneously fold inside and outside of the body based on interactions
between amino acids and different environments.
The ability to predict a protein's shape allows us to better diagnose and treat
diseases that are believed to be caused by misfolding proteins like Alzheimer's,
Parkinson's,
Huntington's,
and cystic fibrosis.
Knowing how proteins operate opens up new potential within drug discovery.
It will enable scientists to create much more effective cures for diseases more
efficiently,
which would ultimately improve the quality of life for millions of patients
around the world.
In fact,
any material with any set of desired properties could be constructed using
proteins.
We could build a material as hard as a turtle shell or as soft as a jellyfish.
We can build liquids that dissolve plastics or the most flexible fibers in the
known universe.
Think of proteins like generalized materials.
If we understood the inverse function of material properties,
meaning their protein structures,
it would change the world far beyond the monetary value of the invention.
We could improve crop efficiency by creating insecticidal proteins or frost
protective coatings.
We could regenerate tissue in disabled veterans through self assembling
proteins.
A whole new realm of cosmetic and enhancement supplements for improved health
could be introduced.
Solving protein folding doesn't just need curing diseases.
It means helping solve world hunger,
enhancing our own physical capabilities and creating new biomaterials.
A protein starts off as a straight string of amino acids chained together in a
unique ordering.
Then an initial folding process occurs that includes a few twists and zigzag
folds,
giving it more of a three d shape.
This folding progress's as component amino acids come together through
attraction,
across disparate lengths of the protein and sometimes the resulting protein will
attach to other proteins after finishing folding in order to function properly.
This whole process is driven by energy minimization.
We can imagine the process of protein folding as a hiking expedition across the
field of rolling hills to find the deepest valley.
The tops of hills described protein folds that are very unlikely to occur and
the valleys described states that the protein is drawn towards the native state.
For a given protein of x amino acids,
there are about three to the x possible folds.
This quickly becomes intractable for proteins of meaningful size,
which contain hundreds of amino acids.
It's a high dimensional landscape.
Trying to predict the shape of it remains difficult for most methods.
Thus far.
Scientists have been able to predict some protein shapes using experimental
techniques like cryo electron microscopy,
nuclear magnetic resonance,
and x Ray crystallography.
Each of these methods is a time intensive process.
Lots of trial and error are involved and it often takes years and tens of
thousands of dollars per structure,
but the rapidly dropping cost of genetic sequencing has increased the amount of
available genetic data to train on,
and this is a major reason why biologists are turning to AI as an alternative to
traditional prediction processes for difficult proteins.
Casp the community wide experiment on the critical assessment of techniques for
protein structure prediction was established in 1994 and became the gold
standard for assessing different protein folding prediction techniques.
It's helped catalyze research and measure progress on the newest methods for
improving the accuracy of predictions.
Eat mind entered into the competition and won against a total of 98 competitors.
Vastly out competing the team winning.
The second place the mind be like Gary,
Brad,
while a team in second place could predict only three of 43 proteins Alpha fold
correctly predicted the structure of 25 of those.
The protein folding problem has been worked on now for over five decades.
The challenge is that DNA only contains information about the sequence of a
proteins,
amino acid chains.
It's building block predicting how these chains will fold into the intricate
three d structures of a protein is the hard part.
Over the years,
as scientists have been able to discover various protein structures using
different techniques,
a database of proteins was compiled called the protein data bank.
It's a Dataset that contains over 146 k proteins and deep mind that use 29 k of
them to train its neural network.
The input would be the amino acid sequence and the output or label is the
collection of coordinates that represent the resulting proteins.
Three d shape,
Yay.
Supervised learning Alpha fold was able to learn the relationship between the
amino acid chains and their resulting protein structures.
Then given a new amino acid chain,
it could predict and associated protein structure.
Alpha fold consisted of two deep residual convolutional neural networks.
We've seen a lot of advances in tasks like image recognition and speech
recognition by simply stacking more layers on to neural networks.
The more layers and network has the deeper it's considered,
but simply stacking more layers onto a network only goes so far and after a
certain threshold accuracy starts to drop.
Microsoft research thought of a brilliant solution to this problem.
Just sorry about that.
Just connect the output of previous layers to the output of new layers.
Assuming you have a three layer network for example,
you wouldn't only pass the output of layer one to layer two and so on,
but you would also add up the outputs of layer one two the outputs of layer to
this residual architecture help them when the image net competition in 2015 and
deep mind repurposed it for protein structure prediction,
there are two resonates predicted the distances between pairs of amino acids and
the angles between the chemical bonds that connect those amino acids.
They use the popular gradient descent to optimization technique using a
combination of these predicted features to optimize full protein chains
structures.
They input the results of their predictions into a three d modeling software
suite called Rosetta to help visualize the resulting proteins.
Rosetta is able to construct a protein structure in both Cartesian and internal
coordinate representations using these features.
In another method they use a generative network called a direct recurrent
attention writer or draw,
but it's not clear how exactly it was used so we're not going there right now.
I also have a great video on how gradient descent works.
By the way,
link will be in the video description,
so that's Alpha fold.
It used this Dataset to generate new structures from a given set of amino acids
and we scored on its accuracy using two deep residual networks.
Dennis,
CEO of deep mines stated that they didn't solve the protein folding problem
entirely,
but it was a first step.
It's likely that the next step for them is to incorporate reinforcement learning
into the pipeline to help increase Alpha folds accuracy.
We have no idea how much computing power was used here,
but I think it's fair to say a lot like all machine learning techniques though
it's only a matter of time before some wizard somewhere finds a way to run it on
a fraction of a fraction of the necessary computing resources.
In fact,
that's the coding challenge for this week.
Replicate Alpha fold as best you can.
Post your get hub link in the comments section of this video and I'll give a
video shout out to the top two entries two weeks from now.
Three things to remember from this video.
Proteins are unimportant component of every cell in the body and if we can
predict how they fold,
then we can cure many diseases.
Boost crop yields massively and enhance our own physical capabilities.
Deep minds Alpha fold use to residual networks to predict the distance between
pairs of amino acids and the angles between chemical bonds that connect those
amino acids.
They optimize these networks using gradient descent and input their predictions
into Rosetta software.
The visualize the resulting proteins in three ultimately placing first in the
CASP competition.
What kind of science experiment you and apply Ai to let me know in the comments
section and please subscribe for more programming videos.
For now.
I've got to release a music video,
so thanks a lot.